all right I got behind this dump truck
but this is one of my favorite things on
the road as far as one of the best
skylines you can ever see I'm in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania you go through
this tunnel you my god this looks like
you know hole tunnel
smells like exhaust in here and when you
come through the other tunnel though
I'll show you the view here this is for
you people who can't I know that you
don't travel but you know vacations in
Pittsburgh all right let's be honest I
didn't realize this tunnel was this
long and run another to say
this is like when there's like a rain
delay they go back to to
greenhorn announcers they run out of
stories all day the Mary had a hunt done
here at this stadium one time and well
you know I was in the middle of telling
a story and I guess I went to inhale as
I was swallowing it choke them shut up
ya I know what to do
alright here we go we're coming out I
see daylight
I see baby alright so you're coming
through here like whatever Pittsburgh
gives a right hockey team with all
the cheap shot artists and their crybaby
players I'm with you I respect
them and all of a sudden you come out of
the tunnel and BAM look at that and you
see that look at that this Heinz Field
over there with a Steelers when
they play can you see it or the
guardrails in the way I think I'm
supposed to make a left here okay
sweetheart look at all the bridges you
know you really up this video
anyways that's one of my favorite things
in the road okay bye